No one knows all the answers,
but I'll.
I'll mention two of them.
Let me say two words.
Television News,
television news.
Fifty years ago when television news was
young,
the philosophy television news is
basically just broadcast news on
television.
It was reporters on television,
somebody trying to say what had
happened.
That was what they did.
You might have 30 minutes of news
without a single televised clip of
anything.
Just somebody that's sitting there
reading the news sometimes at great
length,
that was television news.
It was simply an effort to inform
nowadays never to entertain and to play
to the gallery.
It matters if there are pictures of
matters.
If their jokes you can tell matters,
we'd get.
People want to yell and scream at each
other.
That's really taken us down a sad path
everyone says,
but I think it's true.
That's emphasized the notion that the
right way to have interaction is to get
very strong advocates who will call each
other names.
One thing that's striking about the way
the news is today,
take an issue,
a contested issue,
abortion,
the war,
whatever you like news today is virgo to
telling us people's positions on these
issues.
Candidates say it's very bad at telling
us why they have their positions.
Uh,
it strikes me that one of the jobs of
were news reporters,
not to say so and so is for or against
abortion rights,
but what so and so's argument,
why does so and so I believe that I,
years ago I ran into a guy who was
retired reporter for a major newspaper
and he was lamenting what had happened
to the news and he was telling me how
when he was coming along in the sixties,
if the president announced the New Urban
Affairs Initiative,
the headline would be the next day
President Announces Urban Affairs
Initiative.
And the story would be explaining what
it was.
This is what the president proposed.
That's the story today.
He said,
and we had this meeting in the nineties
today.
He said the story would be Republicans
Attack Presidents Urban Affairs
Initiative as the first paragraph is a
brief token.
Summer was having the secretary or
somebody attacking it third grade
because somebody at defending it,
you never take much time to explain what
it is.
The important thing is who's gonna win?
Who's gonna lose,
who's on which side.
That's one thing.
Certainly that's to help take us down,
but that's not the only thing.
One theory is the big problem.
Luxury.
We've been a generation here.
I speak of myself and the other baby
boomers whose had everything we don't
feel as though we've ever.
They were constantly complaining.
Everything's going wrong in our lives,
but there's a sense which compared to
the rest of world we've had everything
we've everything we could want.
Um,
and that's given us a lot of time to
ruminate,
a maybe too much time to read what I
think our luxury has made us in cautious
in how we use democracy.